okay um I'm opening the subcommittee uh
work session on uh House Bill
1410 and first I want to want to say is
uh we've got two bills amendments uh for
each of them and we have a hard stop at
10 um and they're supposed to be exec
later today so we really need to come to
a decision on these um um promptly so
this 1410 is the one that um you know
we've met a couple times on and uh
nitpick through all the different
changes and I got an amendment on ofs
that combines everything and I didn't
get it till last night so for sorry for
not sending it earlier and I went
through it carefully and hopefully and
verified to my satisfaction um that it
reflects what we asked for but um so
what I'd like to do reasonably briefly
and leave more time for 1676 is if
people have if can look through the
amendment and if you've got any um
questions
concerns 1410 we're starting with yeah
you want to cop you want to copy the
Amendments yeah
okay all
right these will be your copies that too
I I have some ex I don't have twice
as um and I don't know how people want
to proceed um the this amendment
replaces the entire
Bill and and um I can walk through it or
people would like to just look at it um
let me
know be easier just quickly sorry
quickly walk through it yeah
okay I'll do that
so I'm looking at the notes I took um so
we decided on section one which was the
um getting rid of the LNA licensing that
we were going to keep
and so um section what used to be
section one is left out of the bill
entirely as well as some repeals later
on which we'll get to um we decided on
section two it was more this is the
nurse Practice Act Board of
Nursing um we we left out see Pages 8
through 15 yeah the whole thing about
changing the makeup of the board we
decided to keep what's in statute now
and that was um section you know Roman
uh 1 of uh 326 B3 and if you look at the
top of the amendment it starts with um
with Roman two so it leaves one out and
and so it it does what we
wanted
um um correct correct and that means it
stays as is correct stat right and then
we have
um so the other thing we done in section
two is we removed the original lines 21
on page one through um actually went on
quite a
[Music]
ways um
to 20 22 of the following page and so
what is shorter from
establish eligibility criteria for
license or something I don't I'm trying
to look at what is missing what was
struck line 15 of the
amendment that's
um that's the language that's the
language in the original bill was on
page
two um on lines uh 28 through
30 that we had decided to
keep so
this so we're going to remove from the
bill
um section two page one a huge chunk
right there's a huge chunk that we
decided to take out of the
bill and so we took out
um
we
actually yeah we actually removed where
are we here we basically took out all
the
Chang right we took that out
definitely and
then so that keeps it so because we took
that out of the bill that stays as is
right because the the board was being
changed largely to accommodate removing
um the LNA licensing but corre decided
to keep it so um M right along yeah
moving right along one of the things uh
you might notice and I mentioned this to
uh representative mapi is in the
original bill on page 2 13-
22 there are some lines that were struck
out and uh what OS cleverly decided to
do instead of doing it that way they
added in the repeal
section on on page four of the amendment
on line 15
they're repealing 326 B3 uh sections
Roman 9 through Roman 11 which are those
so instead of reproducing them in the
bill and striking them out they uh they
just did it that way so that's fine
page of the of
the um is that you well I was just
looking for that particular you're just
line 15 yeah right yeah but the RSS
don't matter up hang on one second
what's your concern the r the line 15 in
the amendment in the amendment on page
uh page four
okay that's saying that we removed
everything in that big block of the
original um let me see corre okay if
[Music]
you but it doesn't
consider the ones that were here in the
original Bill RSA 4 colon
[Music]
one which the I mean what this is effect
is if you look at the original bill you
look at page one line 7 that's 326 B3
which is the same section and then if
you look down through that section and
you get to the next page starting at
line 13 that's still 326 B3 13- 22
and those are sections Roman 9 through
11 and the on the amendment on p on line
15 of page four it's um it's repealing
those sections I I get it so that I'm
I'm okay with RSA 326
co-b colon 4 that corresponds to the
line on page one but there are two other
rsay the provisions of r RSA 4 colon one
controlling the removal of public
officials um that one and then RSA 91
can you tell me the pages on and lines
on the original bill yeah it's on page
two in the three sections that was
struck line line number okay line number
16 13 line number 21 in page two hang on
line 16 yeah that's in the that's in the
middle of that section 13 22 correct and
and line
21 no mention of it in the amendment
actually that's not true so in the
original
bill they put them there and then Drew
lines through them to remove them right
if the lines strike through that means
it's being removed from statute but they
did it in the amendment in a different
way um on page four of the amendment on
line
15 it repeals s 326 B3 Roman 9 through
11 which are those sections with the
strike through so instead of printing
them here and doing a strike through
they just repeal the sections and it has
the same
effect but that section is not refer in
the amendment anywhere not true is my
question that is not true it because the
on on page four of the amendment line 15
it's
toxi which are Romans
9-1 and those and if you look at the
original bill on page two starting line
13 those are the three sections Roman
910 and 11 that the bill removed by
doing a strike through whereas the
amendment removes them by just
explicitly listing the SE the
subsections
okay yeah yeah
okay
um so there's that and then if we go
back
yeah it's confusing I spent a while last
night trying to yeah that's why thinking
these two are not referred in yeah they
are actually they explicitly are this
one
could I I'm just yeah it's
not this
is they got clever oh that's got clever
and just did it
differently yeah that's why
which is B yeah it's there okay
okay thank you thank you for all
right
um okay so that
was and then we left the rest of we
voted to leave the rest of section to in
place which they
did and then
I just want one
clarification on this one Y which
we
repealed we agreed um the original Bill
page
six
uh 22 23
24 U I'm sorry what page uh the original
Bill Page 6 22 23
24 yeah
and keep the repeal could could before
we get to page six can we go back and
keep working through this in order
because we were kind of on page or did
you get that far I don't think we got
that far no no well the reason I'm
saying is the repeal section it kind of
corresponds with okay the amendment
corresponds with number 10 on page six
to number four on
Amendment right um no I understand but
we did are we okay we went through page
three and four of the original and made
sure the amendment lined up with what we
wanted to do before we jump to page six
okay that's all I'm asking okay yeah
think everybody's trying to keep on
track in their own
way um all right so the original Bill
section three page
two uh lines
203 through Page Three line 20 and
that's the nurse practice we
already powers and duties of the board
so this we uh said we wanted
to leave it as is and and that's all
where are we here in the bill
that's
right the amendment
line through page two line 11 on the
amendment no the Amendment it can't be
page one you mean um line nine actually
right on page
one yeah line
n
yeah original s section two of that and
that continues to page two line 11 and
that is basic it's the
same I look through that and it is the
same so now we're up to of the um of the
bill let me go to the next page so
we did that and now there was uh the
original
section
four and the original section 4 we
wanted to remove that section from the
bill that's what we voted on and that
starts on page three line 21 of the
original bill
um let's see is it right no
that yeah we said to keep that that's
the one where on this copy I didn't um
that's where there was a
change sry where is it on the amendment
that's on uh page two of the amendment
starting at
line
12 is that yeah starting at line 12 okay
and it's it's the
same sorry I put mic on yeah on page
four of the of the original yeah line 2
4 to 28 was where there was a an an
addition and that stays the same and
that's where we want it to be right um
right that's right that's in the
amendment it's page three on lines 14
through 18 cor corre so they just
reproduce that whole section of the book
yeah that's because that's a federal
registry right we want we want to refer
to it yeah
um the um and then okay chair yeah I
have a a question in that yeah um how
does so that has to come in a SE LNA
licensing and registration that's a
separate bill so we're not dealing with
it we are just keeping it in the statute
the way and it'll be addressed in a
separate bill um if if you could come up
uh Doug as I recall you said that this
was included because there's some reason
to to put this reference in there but it
doesn't as I recall Mr chair if I may as
I recall
um director Courtney thought that she
could handle the LNA issues through
policy and procedure that was the uh the
fees and getting the money but that's
separate from what's in this go no my
understanding just to back up what uh
representative I'm yeah I'm going to
really insist on moving along because we
have a hard stop
so Point me where you want me yeah this
was on uh the um the the amend on the
original Bill page 4 24 through 28 which
is adding the reference to 42
CFR oh yeah um we're gonna be doing that
regardless okay so this is just putting
in there what you're doing anyway yeah
okay it's just so people understand
right but it's not really changing
anything correct else okay thank you all
right I'd like to move on to in the
original Bill uh section five page four
starting at line
um page four line I'm sorry section five
page four line 29 um there were um two
changes to the or three changes the uh
criminal history check for nurse
Practice Act the first one was put in
there because we were going to remove
nurse PR I mean
lnas and and so that's no longer needed
since we're keeping lnas there were two
other changes which were uh reflecting
the fact that we gave certain Authority
on feem making and other things uh you
know to oplc rather than the board and
those remain and so if you look at the
amendment page
three um starting at line
19 um through 25 that's it keeps those
changes and gets rid of the one that we
don't need anymore that's correct as we
wanted it right right and then page six
in the original bill
um
that it yeah this is
six
25 I'm trying to get things lined up oh
I'm looking at so
that's page four on Amendment uh page
four right starting at
line we got through I'm trying to get
lined up again um so we got through the
Section Five of the original bill which
is now section four section six of the
original Bill oh the other thing if you
look on the amendment there on uh page
three line 24 there's an a new section
and that was um actually recommended by
by Mr uster house and it's another case
where um
you know we're it's language cleanup
because the fees are no longer with the
board they're with oplc um and so that's
uh there okay so now we're on
to was that only for I thought that was
only for Ln not well it was done for
everything but this one there was one
that was missed when we originally did
it okay can we CL I I thought that
was because the nurses Nurse
Practitioners they pay their dues or the
employ what we did is all board I mean
for all the boards we said the boards no
longer set the fees oplc sets the fees
for everything but this one we missed
and it still gave uh it said the fees
are established by the board so as part
of the rest of this we're taking as
established by the board out
because op oplc sets all fees now and
the problem is we gave the authority
oplc but there's some lingering things
where we left it with the boards and
that's a conflict in statute see that
okay
okay I see the head nodding yes okay and
then um so with that um you know I just
want to go back to the lines in the
original Bill the repeal which page six
22 23 24 the medical technicians yes and
and in the amendment page 4 1213 and
14 which is to be remove I mean repealed
because we don't have the board but
where is the Safeguard to say who has
the authority the
employer um we're I mean that's
generally the employer is liable for
what their employees do we don't need to
say that okay um so we we kept those
repeals there so that that does give OPC
or the employer I just want the
clarification yeah yeah Doug Mr I would
say the employer but then also if the
individual is licensed under an under
another board uh that board would also
have jurisdiction so where would it Go
which board would it go to if it was a
nurse it go to nursing if it was go to
medicine right so the definition of
medical technician as far as this bill
goes excludes anyone that's licensed for
anything else and they're dealt with as
they are today it doesn't change
anything right so they're under some
other board yeah okay thank you no okay
no they're not under any well the
technicians aren't but if you but any
other person who's licens is under their
board medical technicians aren't
licensed and you know and that's
like you know housekeeping various other
things which are not licensed
professions but they work in the
hospital and they're under the employers
you know say under the like a j i mean
if a janitor in any company goes and
harms let's say a customer well then the
company's liable so that's generally
true
yeah so
um we need to move on seriously um sorry
about that but we really really do
because we have a hard stop so if we
look at
um in the original Bill section six
which is
um right so that makes a change because
we were going the bill was going to get
rid of lure it makes changes from lure
to
registration um and and the since we
decided to keep it this whole section uh
goes away and it's not in the
amendment they not all section uh the
original Bill page four line 35 okay and
that goes on to page five line
35 and so all of that is gone which is
what we voted to
do okay and then um the original section
s which is page five line 36 in the
original
bill
um right um that hasn't changed and in
the amendment it's
um well the amendment there's no page
six starts at at right or line 26 sorry
uh
yes okay and then um and that's
correct right and then if we look at the
original page six line five and that's
the Section 8 yep and Section 8 we
wanted to leave the section of the bill
as is which they did
yep um and
then uh yep that's correct right at page
three line S and that goes into the next
page and then in the original bill um on
line
18 it was
um it's you know which which uh boards
that oplc has Authority for and since we
got rid of of the medical technician
registration um we're still taking out
on on page four line 8 of the amendment
it still references
328i but the reference to 328j which was
the nurse practitioners was taken out
because we're going to retain the
license for nurse
practitioners right okay
y
um and then I'm going to go quickly
through the last you know it was 10 now
nine because we're we really need to get
to the next bill the first three as you
had mentioned are still related to the
medical technicians and that chain that
stays um line 15 on page four is the one
we talked about where it keeps those
line the lines are removed that were
removed in the original Bill and then
the rest of these are
um let's see so lines 16 and 17 on page
four of the amendment are more things
where the the statute was in Conflict
it's things that had moved to oplc but
that was not reflected in the board
statute right um that was right we
wanted to keep
those those are lines 27 and 28 on the
original bill right right and
um and okay we left in um license or
application because that was for the
lnas we're keeping the LNA Li
that had to stay um can we just look at
one that uh is all I mean the original
Bill line page
629 in my note says remove this line at
separate section to keep it so and where
is that corresponding that is relative
to licensed that section is um oh it's I
mentioned it earlier relative to license
or
application yeah the one we added
which somebody else can quickly remember
where it was but we just mentioned
it yeah if we can continue um
sorry and um it's it's a I think page
three line 24 um no yes no no no no
that's not right that's not right I'm no
not that
one if somebody finds it you can mention
it but I'm going to move on yep um so on
the
Amendment
um the uh line 18 licensure by
endorsement for lnas we're taking we're
keeping we're keeping that repeal
because there's separate statute on
license by endorsement that we passed
last year and renewal and licens re
instatement we're removing those because
again those are under oplc not the
board and that's the end of
it yeah and we have just over 20 minutes
left for another whole bill so I would
like if somebody make a
motion uh I will make a
motion that we approve the amendment to
House Bill 1410 Amendment 2024
0534 okay all right uh all in favor I
anyone
opposed okay thank
you okay that's all
right
I do actually I've got ones to hand out
to everybody in the full
committee
um all right so going to switch gears
and we're going to um so I'm closing the
subcommittee work session on House Bill
1410 and as soon as I get organized here
I'm opening the subcommittee work
session on House Bill 1676 and this we
have to be very brief um I apologize for
that but we have a hard stop in 20
minutes so I'll just quickly go over
what I did here the statement of purpose
is just what we discussed and voted on
on a previous uh subcommittee
meeting um and then you know the changes
to the membership of the board which is
on
um you know it's the membership starts
on line 22 of page one of the
amendment
is is you know it's what I handed out
basically um it be you know two members
of Edna one from the minority Party U
appointed by the speaker one member of
House consumer affairs appointed by the
speaker same thing for the Senate
appointed by the Senate
President um public member representing
the interest of business in New
Hampshire appointed by the Bia and I
checked with uh leadership in the Bia
and and they're fine with that which I
would expect but they were um uh
executive director of oplc or her design
I'm
wondering um two members of the public
appointed by the governor with consent
of the council and one public member
representing Healthcare employers
appointed by the government with consent
of the council and that one I mean
there's been various ideas on
organizations they should come from
Hospital Association or whatever the
problem is from as far as I could tell
there's not one overarching group that
that represents all the healthcare
workers so I'm leaving it that way um
and it says it's the same language that
we have in all the boards public members
can't hold a license or be a spouse of
them um that that and legislative
members get mileage so we're on page two
and now we're and and the part that was
in the original bill which is um you
know the things for the um the duties of
board for them to compare and there's no
um you know nothing should be read into
the order here they're all there list of
things and there's an or at the end so
they can do any of
them um and is it they have to do any of
them or all of them no any there's an or
so they can pick up few of those and not
do the whole less or or well it's a
matter of these are the options okay you
know what are these are the thing
actually this one is in these are the
things they should consider but it
doesn't tell them what their conclusion
has to
be they should look at these
options and maybe they will look at some
of them very briefly because they don't
think they make any sense and that's
fine
May right it says may include so it's
not requiring them to do any of them
actually but it's it's suggesting those
are things they might want to consider
thank thank you for that I like the fact
that you don't have a deadline Sunset
all those things to hold commission yeah
I was going to get that
basically um you know well I had my view
is to having the repeals might help get
something done I'm not sure how
effective that would be anyway um
because they could get around it just by
getting rid of the repeals and it
generated a lot I mean people perceived
it differently than me which I
understand and uh and so it seemed best
to take that whole thing out of there
which I did and then uh again from the
original bill um you know there's the
rest on page three of six through um
actually you know down to
24 which are things they could do and if
you look at um section seven starting
line six there's a list of things and
again I suggest not reading anything
into the order and that's got an or on
lines 15 which says they can do any of
them and the last one is make no change
to state law so they're you know it's
just telling them what to what to look
at doing and decide what they think is
best and I don't you know the bill
doesn't control that it's going to be up
to the commission and it says the
commission Also may comment on each
licensing board's composition like we've
reviewed compositions of boards and the
authority of the law delegates to
promate administrative
rules um and particularly rules relating
to establish a scope of practice and the
qualifications to gain a license and
those are you know two of the key rul
making areas that boards are involved in
and then some other things they can
comment on but they may comment on Le
these things for them to think about as
the idea in section
nine and then there's already in statute
a thing where you know unless the the um
the bill creating the commission States
otherwise all commissions automatically
expire after five years but in uh
discussion with chair Maguire she
suggested adding it here explicitly
which in section three lines 25 and 26
um do that um
where sorry if you lost me uh if you
look at line 25 and 26 prospective
repeal it says relative to evaluate
various occupational boards and
commissions and to recommend needed
changes is repealed and if you look at
the effective date section it says
section three of this act will take
effect December the 31st 2029 which is
the five years oh that's okay I get it
that's that's a very convoluted way to
say that but I ol I just told them to
have it repeal after 5 years and this is
how all US did it
so you know my on this is I still feel
this is a little premature having just
implemented this major change last year
which hasn't been implemented this is
not statutary commission or committees
it is the regulatory boards in the
commission or committee this is looking
at all the licensing 16 76 what
representative Dolan is looking at is
all the other commissions outside I mean
if if his commission were to be
recreated or continued it would look at
the commission created by this not not
the licensing board correct and correct
and I hope that won't be necessary
because it auto repeals So to avoid that
I mean I just I I I understand your
concern what I would say is
um you know the big changes we
made um last year and some this year
were you know some changes in oplc
giving them additional Authority and all
of that but the basic functions of the
boards I we made there's some bills to
change some of them but the basic
functions of boards which are you know
the rulle making around what are the
requirements to be licensed and what's
the scope of practice and and other
things like that for most of the boards
that doesn't change and there's nothing
in here that tells the commission what
what order they have to take the boards
in I mean they can take start with the
boards that are have changed the least
or more stable and look them over and
maybe they're going to decide that maybe
there's some minor changes needed maybe
nothing um that would be up to the
commission um and you know they can
leave the ones that maybe there's been
more significant changes to later it's
over five years so that's why I'm not
concerned representative G thank you Mr
chair my question is going along with
this theme and not wanting to just keep
creating new commissions and committees
that aren't necessary isn't there
already an oplc commission or committee
looking at oplc and how is this
different and why is it needed there is
an oplc oversight committee which uh I
and chair Maguire are on
and it's only had a couple meetings so
it's be you know it's not entirely clear
how it's going to work but what it looks
like is looking at current issues that
have come up uh but it's not set up and
it looks like it's not going to be
taking a deep dive
into um you know the the statutes and
the rules of each individual board so
it's not going to do this it's been
more um you know getting uh director
Courtney or someone to report on how
rule Mak is going on some of the things
we did last year and um you know getting
concerns raised by people who are
licensed and then you know talking to
people at opl having people at oplc talk
to the committee about you know what
what why what's going on with that and
it's it's kind of an ongoing keeping an
eye on them and trying to um learn of
problems early on and hopefully deal
with them promptly and not have concern
you know in the licensed Community or or
in consumers either one build up okay so
um what I'm hearing is that oversight
committee is uh looking at the process
the procedural work of oplc where this
commission would be analyzing the boards
and and making recommendations correct I
mean there's nothing to prevent the
oversight committee from looking at the
statute and rules uh but it it's not
um it's kind of not really their charge
to do that it's more ongoing things and
looking at how I mean the chair is
Senator Carson and looking at how she's
um choosing to run the committee it's
more
um uh looking at concerns people have
about
oplc um and um you know keeping up with
how they're implementing the statutory
changes that have gone into place over
the last you last year this year
represent man yeah isn't the role of the
board to evaluate the current situation
market and the profession and Licensing
the workforce issue all those things are
inh apparently the
board the licensing board part of it is
there you would you would hope so uh but
ultimately you know the authority over
licensing and what the boards are doing
is with the legislature and this is a
commission made up majority as required
of
legislators um you'd like to think the
board was doing that but I mean we've
seen cases where that doesn't seem to be
the case now there are the other
question raised at one time was a
performance audits what performance
Audits and they're good but they're like
the one we have with the Dental Board
and the Mental Health Board the last
while they're looking at is the board um
following statute are they doing what
the legislature told them to do and are
they doing it in an efficient manner and
that's an important thing but it but
it's not their job to say you know is
the
statute um correct because that's what
the legislature and it's also it's only
their job to look at the rules to the
extent do the rules correspond to what
the authority given in statute um and
and are they you know leading them to
operate in an efficient manner um and so
it's it's an important job but it's a
different job than than I think this
Commission job would be okay uh
representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair um I in my mind I think the the
amendment here we've come to a good
balance between where we started with
the concerns about sunsetting
commissions without any guarantee
that uh sunsetting boards excuse me
without any guarantee that the
commission would do any work I think
we've solved that and I think it remains
in place for those that have a little
bit of a concern about the maybe the
overbearing nature of of board
regulations so I think that this strikes
a really good balance between the
concerns on both sides of the table all
right thank
you um I I'm going to move forward I'm
not not taken I mean is anybody else
who's on the subcommittee have anything
to say and then I think we need to go to
a
motion um you want to would your motion
be at the uh it would be um to um that'
actually be two motions one is to adop
and actually on the other one we should
have done an otpa one but it's to um to
recommend the adoption of this amendment
so I would I would do that make a motion
that we vote to
approve the amendment to House Bill 1676
Amendment 2024
d478 H okay thank you a
[Music]
second uh Bailey
okay all right
um so this is accept the amendment and
um I'll I'll go around representative
Brown hi um representative Bailey yes
representative G ruled yes represent
mapy yes and the chair votes yes so
that's 5 to zero and then I think I need
to make and I may go back to the other
one um I'll accept an otpa yeah so make
make a motion for ought to pass as
amended for House Bill 1676 with the
amendment 2024 47h okay 478 H
and uh representative Bailey
seconds um so all in favor
hi anyone opposed hi uh re okay thank
you and and then yeah I got it we'll go
back to I make a motion to well hang on
I got to do something official for I'm
closing the subcommittee work session of
house bills 1676 and reopening the one
on um House Bill
1410 and yes I'll accept a motion okay
so make a motion went ought to pass as
amended with Amendment yes otpa 14 on
House Bill
1410 Amendment 202 4-05
34h okay I'll I'll second it um we are
just accepting the amendment it's it's
right we accepted the amendment but I
neglected to make the second motion
which is to recommend the whole bill as
amended um so all in
favor anyone opposed I okay thank you I
assume you're not saying voting to be
opposed but no
14 some concerns that's you know yeah
yeah
um okay all right thank you I'm closing
the subcommittee work session on House
Bill 1410 and we are
done thank you everybody for
um a lot of work I mean 1410 was a lot a
lot of nitpicky details and thank you to
everybody who came and helped us on
these and
um all right now we
can move on thank you Mr chair for doing
such a wonderful job and letting us all
speak our mind yeah I mean I I don't
know
everything thank
you
that
way all right W welcome to
Edna uh today we are going to be
executing all of our early bills and a
few
others
um and I wanted to give people a heads
up on the schedule we have two days of
hearings next week on Tuesday and
Wednesday the following week we have
hearings on
Wednesday and that is the last of the
hearings that I know about
we'll probably get second committee
bills but those will be after the
vacation week um the deadline for all
our other bills is March
21st so there's plenty of time for
subcommittee work on the bills we have
remaining but uh I'm going on vacation
it's the first time Edna has not had to
schedule things during vacation week in
a long
time
so all right and uh but yeah that's
it and my plan for today is to start
with
the
um with the pension bills do the LI do
the licensing bills after lunch assuming
that we aren't finished before
lunch and finish up with the time change
because those those aren't early bills
and we don't need to finish them this
today
all right so representative Simon you
have a motion
on which one
1647 all right
1647 thank you madam chair I would like
to move uh Amendment
0326 H for hb1
okay Simon
moves all to pass and presents Amendment
0326 and it should be among the pile of
Pap papers at everybody's place and is
there a second to this
motion I'll
second so that's represent
blackis okay do you wish to speak to
your motion uh yes thank thank you madam
chair uh so 1647 um addresses group two
workers um multiplier for their um
annual their final average compensation
and um the bill itself is a almost $56
million bill and we felt the need to
bring the cost down a little bit so the
amendment is a cost-saving measure it's
also potentially um a retention measure
and basically says that in order to get
the increased multiplier after their
their first 10 years of credible service
um they have to um have at least
attained the age of 60 regardless of the
number of years of credible service or
they have to work up to their full uh
age and service requirements in order to
get that added multiplier if they fail
to do one of those two things um then
they will keep the current multiplier
which is 2% instead of the
2.5% um the other thing that the
amendment does uh is creates a carve
out um for those with uh ordinary
disability or qualify for an accidental
death benefit so that uh you know if
they die or um end up under ordinary
disability um and they haven't put in
the full age or service requirements
they can still qualify for the 2.5%
after the first 10 years of credible
service so those are the two things um
that the amendment does uh we felt like
those were reasonable compromises to
help bring the cost down without um
causing additional hardship to the
members with a greater need and uh I
hope the committee will consider the
amendment okay represent leus do you
wish to speak to your second
okay I'd like to mention that this bill
was the result of the retirement
commission and that was not supported in
committee by the Republican legislators
or the counties as a representative of
employers because of the
cost this amendment while
maintaining the
um getting the annuity multiplier up to
where it used to
be still manages to be about the the
amount of money that the Senate is
willing to commit to this this plan so I
think it's a reasonable compromise that
we should send on to finance and get an
exact cost uh
we're we don't have one yet as modified
but it is actually better than some of
our
previous
um suggestions in the retirement system
in that it applies to new hires as well
as to existing retirees and it will keep
will give the new hires and short-term
members eventually the same benefits as
every everyone else in in group two so
I'm I'm fully supporting it anyone else
want to
comment all right in that case the
motion is to adopt Amendment
0326 call the
RO representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative s oaso yes
representative Dolan yes
representative Popovich Mueller yes
clerk V yes representative Boy Yes
representative Brown yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes and
the chair
yes 20 a0 a all
right repr Simon you have a motion uh
yes Madam chair I would like to move a
to pass with Amendment all right is
there a second
second okay do you wish to speak to your
motion um anything that I could say I
believe that you said during your
testimony so I think we've got it pretty
well covered okay representative goalie
do you have a comment I agree with
repres representative Simon okay any
further
discussion all right in that case the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
0326 on House Bill 1647 and the clerk
can call the role representative Simon
yes representative lakus yes
representative Bailey yes representative
saso yes representative Dolan yes
representative popovic Mueller yes clerk
votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
maputi yes and the chair yes 20a z a all
right this will not go on consent
there's too much money
involved all
right house bill 1211
part-time employment of a retirement
system retiree can you get somebody for
that oh it
was representative Simon thank you madam
chair I'd like to move itl on
hb21 all right
second that's represent brto yes okay do
you wish to speak to your motion uh yes
thank you madam chair um during
testimony uh we were told that members
who are um doing part-time work uh
aren't coming close to the present hours
already allotted to them so raising the
number of hours um isn't going to
benefit them at all and it's also going
to push the number of available hours up
into the realm where it becomes
questionable whether or not they should
really just be back on full-time paying
into the retirement system so that it
doesn't dilute the system as a whole um
so for those reasons uh we didn't feel
like this was an appropriate solution uh
to our um shortage staff shortage um so
we want to move itl on it Vera thank you
Madame chair we've addressed this um
type of U Bill many times before and I
think this committee feels comfortable
with the precedent that we've set with
the ex with the current
hours okay anyone else wish to
speak okay in that case the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1211 and the clerk can all the RO
representative Simon yes representative
leakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santos Sasso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
popovic Mueller yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative Gro yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes representative
maner py yes and the chair yes 20 a0
n all right any objections to
consent okay we will put that one on
consent uh House Bill
1307 supplemental appropriation for
disability retirement
um represent vus you have a motion can I
make a motion of I to pass um with
Amendment all
right what number is the amendment uh 0
five1 Z
0510 which will
be passed around everybody should
everybody should have one
okay so that's moved by representative
Davis is there a second also okay move
seconded by representative
Simon representative
Davis you wish to speak to your
motion this bill seeks to put into a
statute that those on accidental
disability benefits receive all the
callers and uh supplemental appr
Appropriations authorized by the
legislature in the future this is to
include the onetime supplemental
appropriation pass last year of
$500 um
somehow um accidental disability
uh people members uh were left out of
um the bill last year so this seeks to
give them that money and also to make
sure that uh they're treated equally in
the
future all right R Simon thank you madam
chair the amendment before the committee
uh simply raises the um allowance for
those uh members whose pay in 2023 was
not greater than $50,000 as opposed to
$40,000 that'll add another I think it
was 85
86 70 to 80 70 to 80 people um who
typically get left out of um these
stiens so we wanted to make sure that
they were included and the cost isn't
going to be very exorbitant so we felt
like that was
reasonable the re the and I I'd like to
say that one reason for the increase is
that it's largely group two members who
do not receive Social Security so their
pension is larger than a group one
pension because of that
um
okay any further comments questions
concerns okay the motion is to adopt
amendment
0510 to House Bill 1307 and the clerk
can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon naso
yes representative Dolan yes
representative popovic Mueller yes clerk
vot yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis
yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative G yes representative
Smith yes representative mapy yes and
the chair yes 20 a0 n all right
representative Davis you have a
motion yes I to pass with
Amendment second
by I'll second
okay do you wish to speak to your
motion I think I covered everything
I have nothing to add to what
representative Davis said okay anyone
else wish to comment question
discuss seeing none the motion is ought
to pass with amendment
0510 to House Bill 1307 and the clerk
can call the role representative Simon
yes representative lakus yes
representative Bailey yes representative
santon staso yes representative Dolan
yes representative poit Mueller yes clar
vote Yes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
manuti yes and the chair yes 208 z a all
right I don't think this should go on
consent because of the dollar
amount all right moving right along
House Bill
1653 representative Simon thank you
madam chair I would like to move interim
study on hb1
1653 there a second I'll
second okay do you wish to speak to your
motion yes thank you madam chair um the
bill is uh one of many bills that we
received um that looks to adjust the
retirement benefit for members who of
group two who were employed before um is
it July of 2000 July 1st 2011 but hadn't
been vested um by
2012 um in this particular uh bill um
they were looking to increase those
benefits um by allowing overtime pay to
be included as base pay and also um for
those who commend service honor after
July uh before July uh 1st 2011 um for a
compensation for extra and special duty
to be included in the
calculations um even even those who are
strongly in support of 1653 um agreed at
subcommittee that hb1 1647 is the
priority piece of legislation this year
if we were to pass both 1647 and this
bill um who which Standalone cost is um
is this the 26 million or the 18
million uh was 27 million would uh not
just be the 27 million because it would
build on top of hb1 1647 and increase it
even more than that um so we didn't want
to get in the way of hb1 1647 and it was
just to pricey for consideration this
year so for those reasons we're
recommending I to the committee
representative broa do you wish to speak
to your second I'm sorry interm study
interm study yes yes I no I think that
representative Simon feel spoke
effectively on it thank you all right
thank
you anyone else comments questions
all right the motion is interim study on
House Bill 1653 and the clerk can call
the
role represent Simon yes represent lakas
yes represent Bailey yes represent
santon staso yes representative do uh
Dolan representative popovic Mueller yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
represent
goalie yes representative Shu yes
representative
O'Brien yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes and
the chair yes 20 a0
a are there any objections to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that on
consent house Bill
1673 representative
Simon thank you madam chair I'd like to
move interim study on hb1 1673 is there
a
second second
second remind the committee that
seconding does not commit you to writing
a committee report so uh feel free to
Second at your leisure
good representative Simon uh thank you
madam chair uh this is an another one of
the bills that um sought to increase the
benefits for that group of members I
referred to previously um by changing
the um the percentage of um compensation
above base pay um once again it it's a
large cost concern even if you're
sympathetic to the arguments of the bill
um 1647 Still Remains the priority piece
of legislation and this one um was going
to be $18 million I believe um Plus the
added expense of adding it to hb1 1647
which would have increased it even more
um so for those reasons we're moving
interim study okay person
gr I I have nothing to add thank
you anyone
else all right in that case the motion
is interim study on House Bill
1673 and the clerk can call the rooll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative
saso yes representative Dolan yes
representative pich Mueller yes clerk
vot yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
gr yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative
O'Brien yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative manager py yes
and the chair yes 20 a0 a all right any
objections to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that one on consent
also House Bill
1421 representative Schmidt you have a
motion I move what uh at is there a
second
second that's representative gold all
right Schmid do you to speak to your
motion yes I believe the intent of this
bill originally was to attempt to reform
and redesign the
um investment committee and uh in the
course of the uh vetting of the bill was
discovered that the post concept really
didn't work uh and the the sponsor
himself requested that the bill be ital
so happy to oblig represent ghoul do you
wish to speak to your second I think M
uh representative Schmid said it well
okay anyone else questions
comments all right um the motion is inex
to legislate on House Bill
1421 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative sanon
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Popich meller yes clerk
votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
manati yes and the chair yes 20 a0
a any objections to
consent all right we'll put this one on
consent all right the last retirement
Bill House Bill 1299 represent Simon you
have a
motion yes Madam chair I'd like to move
all to pass on H uh on Amendment 03000 H
which everybody should
have all right is there a
second
second okay
gold
seconds do you wish to speak to your
motion yes thank you madam chair um so I
I would say that coming out of
subcommittee
um the autop pass motion is is more a
desire to just bring the idea before the
whole committee and have a conversation
about it um more so than we feel very
very strongly about it um I think
everybody can see both sides of the
issue um but this bill was brought the
original bill was brought before us um
because the instructors at the fire fire
education uh fire education um at the
community college uh were indicating
that they were having a difficult time
um hiring qualified candidates for that
position um and they wanted to have uh
members who had 10 years of fire service
experience be able to keep their um
group two benefits retirement benefits
and then move over and take one of these
teaching positions uh the community
college system as you can see from
testimony is against this they don't
want to have two different kinds of
groups um at the college system uh which
is a reasonable argument um the reason
why I'm bringing this uh Amendment
forward is it would up um it would up
the requirement to 20 years of fiber
fire service experience um before a
member could be considered to move over
into one of these positions and maintain
their benefits
um my my biggest concerns after talking
to people are that it seems to me that
the people that we want teaching these
courses are people who have actual field
experience um they are teaching the next
group of
firefighters um you know the skills that
they will need to protect the rest of
the community from fire um if we are
indeed having a hard time getting those
kinds of people to take these positions
because they'll end up potentially
taking a substantial cut to their
retirement benefit if they do which was
the testimony that we received um then I
would love to see some sort of mechanism
for them to be able to keep their
benefits and teach these uh in in these
positions um I know that there's
concerns that we don't typically you
know um pass legislation for a couple
people which I agree with but I actually
think this brings these Educators more
in line with other people who um teach
uh either at the fire academy or even
with police uh with Fire Chiefs um who
aren't still typically fighting fires
out in the field um but can still
maintain their group two benefits uh it
seems from that perspective that uh we
would just be including these um and not
making a special exception for these
particular educators
um and the last thing that I would say
is we opted to 20 years because the
purpose of group two benefit without
question um is the benefit is there
because uh the members are putting life
and limb on the line every day and after
only 10 years uh it didn't seem fair to
the rest of group two members um to
allow them to switch over to this
particular kind of job and maintain that
benefit but my feeling was potentially
after 20 years of actual firefighting uh
service in the field putting life and
limb on the line um getting fairly close
pretty close to their you know full age
and service requirements um that having
them move into this position um to once
again stay active teaching the next
generation of firefighters was not so
different as I said before from Fire
Chiefs or from those who work at the
fire academy um so just wanted to to
bring that to the attention of the
committee and and have some conversation
and see what other people felt about it
represent ghoul do you wish to speak to
your
second oops thank you madam chair I just
think the committee did a really good
job uh blending two different points of
view anyone else representative goalie
thank you madam chair and I'll be voting
against this amendment and if it comes
forward against the bill itself
um well I feel the need you know see the
need for instructors that have the
expertise and experience in the field um
once again we just look
at robbing heater to pay Paul because
you're taking a seasoned 20-year veteran
in the fire service to leave that
position to go to a position we're
hearing is hard to
fill but you need to really go back and
look at the municipality you just took
that firefighter that has that
experience from in the position they're
having to fill and they have the same
problem filling that
position that's one of the reasons okay
but the other reason if I may continue
is
you're G to you are going to come into
the position where you could be paying
two employees doing the same exact job
two different benefits one who's come
from group two over into that position
and someone who may have come from
either out of state or just here in New
Hampshire that was never in group two is
only receiving group one
benefits you heard in testimony oh well
they there wouldn't be an issue with
that
well I'm telling you if you were in that
Workforce and that was happening I'm
sure you would raise a stink and say
well I want my position in group two as
well because I'm doing the same job he's
doing right here and right now um so for
those reasons I I can't votee for this
thank you
okay representative Pap Miller thank you
uh not having been here during the
hearings I I just wanted to ask um you
know if the committee is basically
trying to help C C csnh when ccsnh says
they don't need this help thank you very
much what what was said during testimony
that leads us to you know supporting a
bill to help ccsnh against their own
objections I just want it was more a
matter of considering the
employees in in that position and those
who might be hired to fill those
positions not
necessarily the community college system
which as you say doesn't really want
that help repr GR
okay yes I do want to um support the
comment that um representative goalie
made my concern is that the Community
College then is put into a situation
where they have two employees doing the
same job and
um for the The Experience that's
required is already being met by someone
who's teaching there so I don't support
I mean although I understand the
amendment and I support the work that
was done for the amendment I will not be
supporting the amendment or the bill
okay represent Simon thank you madam
chair just I wanted to clarify a couple
things and thank you for kindly stating
that um it's it's a strange Fusion of
two different worlds um most of fire
training doesn't happen in the education
system it happens at the fire academy at
least my understanding um so when the
crossover happens in the actual College
system you've got this kind of strange
intermingling of people who sometimes
qualify for group two in group one
positions and and whether or not when
they leave one group and go to the other
uh they can maintain their benefits and
whether or not that's going to be a
hindrance to them doing so um so I you
know I understand the college systems
situation and and why they're asking
what they're asking I think it's
completely reasonable once again the the
amendment's been brought forward to see
how the committee felt about it not so
much to strongly push one one position
or the other so I just want to make sure
that people have information I don't
want to give uh
false okay representative Schmidt no
no oh thank you I was just going to look
over that side representative leus uh
thank you although I'm going to oppose
the bill for a number of the reasons
mentioned especially by representative
goalie I'm going to support the
amendment I mean I'm hoping we don't
pass this but if it does if we're going
to give these people group too I'd
rather they have had their 20 years
experience it makes more sense so thank
you okay represent were you making a
comment okay you're good anyone else
questions all right the motion is to
adopt Amendment
0300 to House Bill 1299 and the clerk
can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon oaso
yes representative Dolan yes represent
poic Mueller yes votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes Representative groa
no representative Schmidt no
representative goalie no Representative
sht no representative
O'Brien no representative Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick no
representative G
yes representative Smith
yes represent manuti
no 12a two name um yeah I'm sorry oh in
the chair I apologize I'm trying to keep
up with the account in the chair my
apologies could I hear that
again 12a 8 a right okay the U
representative Simon
thank you madam chair I will move ought
to pass with amendment is there a
second second by representative Brown
okay any you wish to speak to your
motion uh no that's not okay anyone else
representative yeah you can
Brown uh no no comment anyone else wish
to speak to the uh to the motion
represent Goldie thank you madam chair
and for the reason stated uh earlier I
will be voting against the
otpa excellent anyone else
representative gold I'll just quickly
say I seconded the amendment because um
I support anything to do with the fire
academy after hearing the arguments um I
won't be voting for the bill as amended
which will seem odd so I thought I'd
make a statement
all right thank you for that information
we uh we're glad to have it okay the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on House Bill
1299 further discussion the clerk will
call the role representative Simon I
really throw you for a loop
representative Golds uh
no Representative lakas no
representative Bailey no represent
santon naso no representative Dolan no
representative Popovich Mueller no clerk
votes no uh representative Boyd no
representative Brown no Representative
groa
no representative
Schmidt turn my microphone on
no represent goalie no represent Shu no
representative O'Brien no representative
Davis no representative Fitzpatrick no
representative gold
no representative Smith no
representative Manti no and the chair
no all right so the motion
fails represent Simon you have an
alternate motion yes Madam chair uh
thank you for the time and the
discussion uh from the committee became
evident throughout the course of it um
so
itl seconded by representative go I
believe all right do you wish to speak
to your motion uh yes thank you madam
chair like I said originally um in its
in its original form nobody was in
support I appreciate people's attention
to the amendment um but it became
obvious during conversation that people
have concerns about this I think those
concerns are reasonable so I think itl
is a is a suitable motion all right
anyone represent goalie I think I've
stated my reasons okay anyone else have
a comment
questions okay in that case the motion
is it expedient to legislate on House
Bill
1299 and the clerk can call the role
represent zimon yes representative lakas
yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santos Sasso yes
representative doar Dolan representative
poic Mueller yes clerk root yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative GH yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 280
name motion passes any objection to
consent
okay we'll put that one on
consent okay and that I believe is all
the retirement
issues so moving on to something
completely different representative Shu
you have a motion on House Bill
1324 House Bill
sorry uh I'll move interim
study okay do you wish to speak to your
motion yes um this bill uh dealt with
green burials although uh the bill
actually was creating a whole new um
category of disposing of human remains
and um during the course of the hearing
and the subcommittee meeting there were
many questions raised that were
unanswered and so we basically charged
the sponsors and supporters to uh
investigate the possibility of answering
these questions and coming up with
Solutions possible
compromises uh with folks that had
questions and to that end uh the
subcommittee voted for to nothing for
interim study to allow them time to do
that
work Smith do you have a comment I think
uh representative should have did um
explain it very well it was a lot of
conflicting testimony but also just too
many unanswered questions so that we
really uh need to look into this because
I think it raises the the subject is is
is one that uh deserve further
examination so I certainly will support
the interim study any anyone else
represent laus yeah well I uh I support
the idea and during the public hearing I
didn't hear any testimony that I thought
raised serious concerns I wasn't at the
subcommittee and hearing that so given
that um I'll go along with the interim
study man py thank you madam chair I do
second uh interim study for a reason
that it's a good option it's a nice way
to go another option for end the life
thank you yeah i' I'd like to say that
green
burial however defin is available now so
we don't need to authorize it the
uh natural organic
reduction seems like a much more
complicated process it has not been
successfully regulated in I believe it's
New York or or Connecticut that have
authorized it they don't have their
rules
yet maybe it's Massachusetts anyway they
were two nearby States and the other
issue is that that process produces
something like a cubic yard of what it
calls
soil and I was concerned that
the they didn't have a good good way of
dealing with it it's we don't I don't
think we want them to sell that as you
know clean
fill um exact we want a respectful
disposition and it's not it's not
covered
yes anyone
else all right seeing none the motion is
interim study on House Bill 13 24 and
the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo naso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
popovic Mueller yes clerk vote Yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 2a0
n any objections to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that on consent
also
and House Bill
1466 I I have an
amendment where is
it it's amendment
number
0528 H which you should have I'll
second Shu
seconded
and if anyone wants extra copies I've
got a
few anyway we had a subcommittee
subcommittee meeting on this bill it
talked about what the intent was and how
the bill was being
interpreted we found out that the
department of safety and Emer of
Department of emergency emergency
management is completely Federal funded
and they don't have a way to deal with
State
funds so they were using this bill as an
excuse to set up a complete parallel
bureaucracy which was not
favored uh they're hiring five new
people going to create a new set of
rules the whole bit so after talking
with that
department and representative Wier who
explained how the fiscal committee
Works representative Shu and I
completely rewrote the bill so that what
it does is it explicitly gives
a
town the authority to request from the
fiscal
committee
grants um limited to $100,000 a year but
the exact amount is at the discretion of
the fiscal committee based on the
disaster or the amount of money that's
on hand of
course and the intention is
that if a disaster occurs what these
small towns seem to need most is a
little bit of cash in their pocket so
they can get keep going uh they need
to uh if they're going to be borrowing
money they need to schedule a town
meeting if they're going to be applying
for a FEMA Grant which most of them will
they need to conduct an assessment of
the roads and and get an estimate of the
damage and that's not
instantaneous so we figured a uh giving
them some cash upfront should help them
deal with the
disaster and it it seemed like an
appropriate thing for the state to do is
to support some of these
municipalities so that that's the
amendment um I hope it will hope it will
work the int we intend is that this
could this money could be used for
matches for FEMA grants or state grants
but if it doesn't
that's okay we we don't know the rules
well enough to write how to how to make
sure that it could be used but we would
like to it to be used as matching funds
representative shuid and then leus thank
you yes I'll just add that um we saw
this as a way to get more immediate
relief uh for just temporary things such
as um in the case of the sponsor it was
the main road through her town that has
become
impassible uh Bridges things of that
sort and it was mentioned that yes these
towns can generally get loans to help
with these things but in order to obtain
a loan they have to call a Town Meeting
which takes time and uh some expense so
we felt this was the right thing to
do represent lus thank you I just want
to make sure my understanding of the
amendment is correct so this $100,000
limit would be uh per municipality but
the fisical committee could Grant up to
that for more than one municipality for
an emergency yes okay thank
you per municipality per
year represent BR thank you and so this
is this money is actually called relief
so it's not a grant per
se and it is something that would not be
expected to be paid back is that correct
yes
because for one thing the town couldn't
accept a loan in any short period of
time without I have to call a Town
Meeting representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so I want
to emphasize what representative shuart
said that that is kind of implicit but
the bottom line here is that they need
money
quickly uh and the FEMA process can be
quite protracted uh and uh and uh all
every every aspect that it was
referenced involves delay they need the
money fast yes and uh we decided to
leave the Declaration of a
disaster at the governor's level since
he already has that Authority we didn't
want to complicate things by giving the
commissioner of safety the authority to
uh declare a disaster figure the
governor will notice as quickly as
anyone else any other comments
questions okay yes represent Brown oh
sorry man py sorry thank you Madame
chair um leaving the governor the
authority to declare emergency and state
owning the funds to give it so that way
it's not um passing down the
responsibility to
the municipalities or the towns to hold
the ball as I think it's not downward
shifting so it makes a good compromise
in terms of providing the immediate need
okay thank you represent Brown uh thank
you madam
chair so in in the original bill it was
they shall not receive more than $5
million in a calendar year and now we're
at a h 100,000 that's a maximum of
100,000 per year is that correct right
this does not include regular disaster
grants it does not include FEMA grants
or matching funds for FEMA grants it's
just from
this quick access money followup
yes would am I wrong in thinking that
the the sponsor thought that this $5
million would would not include either
of those things you mentioned and it
would come from a fund
correct yes okay thank you we we
discussed it with the sponsor at the um
at the subcommittee and focused in on
the main goal was not so much to
completely fund the repairs of the
infrastructure so much as to get a
little cash up front understood thank
you so we changed the purpose of the
bill all right anyone
else all right so I have the motion is
to adopt Amendment 5
28h to House Bill 1466 and the clerk can
call the role representative Simon yes
representative Lakers
yes representative Bailey yes
representative saso yes representative
Dolan yes representative popovic Mueller
yes clerk votes yes representative boydd
yes representative Brown yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie
yes representative Shu yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 20 a09 all
right and I move ought to pass with
Amendment 0528 on House Bill
1466 second second okay and I think I've
said everything I need to representative
sh sh it seconded and
uh any further questions comments or
discussion all right the motion is ought
to pass with Amendment on House Bill
1466 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative Lakers yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo naso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Povich Mueller yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative Gro yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes representative
maputi yes and the chair yes yes 20 a0 a
all right this one can't go on consent
because of the money
but think about
it
okay all right house bill 1689
representative Gro you have a motion I
do um Madam chair I wish to move interim
study on House Bill
1689 is there a second
second
Sher
okay you should speak to your motion yes
thank you so um we had an a subcommittee
meeting on this and it became apparent
that there are many components to this
um request that are interrelated and it
needs a much deeper dive than we have
time for in um our subcommittee so we
are asking to interim study so that we
can spend time to ident to uh new really
work those uh conflicts out and
understand bit of the process because we
do think that um personal
identification protection is
important okay person
gold uh I agree with everything that
representative groy said and I do think
that um that both sides have uh equal
concerns and needs and need to be looked
at so I'm happy that we're recommending
to take the time and
study okay representative leus thank you
I understand there's some problems but
uh we've had uh bills addressing this in
the past
that um you know where where
the protection of personal information
was left out for you know various
reasons and there are arguments on the
other side um I can't I'm not going to
vote in I'm study on this um
but you know if that's what the
committee decides I'm not going to
object to consent if that ends up being
possible
so anyone else for those who don't
remember House Bill 1689 is the use of
personal identifying information by
state agencies in particular between
data transfer between the archives and
vital records and Department of Health
and Human
Services anyone else comment
comments all right the motion is interim
study on House Bill 1689 and the clerk
can call the
role representative Simon yes
Representative lakas no representative
Bailey yes represent santon naso no
represent Dolan yes represent poic
Mueller no clerk Road no represent Boyd
no representative Brown yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes represent
O'Brien oh he left the
room representative Davis
yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative G yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes yes
and the
chair
yes 14 y five
nay all right
the the motion of interim study
passes and Madam chair may I ask may I
ask for one minute recess to make sure
that um just a check on representative
O'Brien
uh yes this bill will not will be on the
regular calendar I'll be right back and
we will take actually let's take a five
minute recess
what does anyone wish to write a
Minority Report on House Bill
1689 okay needs to be uh written by
today
and
uh Dan can't sign
it so who's the
fifth Tony did you vote
no I'm trying to figure out who the
fifth person s also l s Ah that's that's
who it is hey up how are you good how
are
you yes very shortly
all right
representative O'Brien is uh we hope he
will be resting and he will be able to
join us after lunch so I plan to take up
a few of
the bills that we probably won't be
debating much and then break for
lunch
so on House Bill
1070 represent Senator blus you have a
motion yes um I'd like to make an itl
motion on House Bill 1070 I'll second
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
I do
um so what this bill did is it it uh it
said that um employees departments and
you know all parts of the executive
branch were not permitted to uh violate
the USR Federal Constitution uh due to
you know while following orders of the
governor under state of emergency
however and you know I certainly hope
that at least in obvious cases they
wouldn't um but some cases may not be
clear and we already have put in statute
not that long ago in RSA
445 it says um you know notwithstanding
the foregoing enumerated powers civil
liberties shall on NOA count be
suspended nor shall the United States uh
or the New Hampshire Constitution be
suspended and so it would be uh against
statute for the governor to give them
such an order and you know the uh U and
I I actually talked to representative uh
uh Lynn about the details on how things
would be interpreted and um and he said
you know
it the really the in court the
appropriate way if you think something
you know that the constitution has been
violated would be to uh to bring a case
against either the governor for
violating the statute and the
Constitution um or perhaps a department
head but um going after the individual
employees um you
know doesn't necessarily make sense I
would put them in a difficult position
well you know I was following orders is
an excuse but not every situation is
that clear and therefore I think we
should just itl it because it's already
covered in statute okay represent BR you
wish to make comment on your second no I
think representative luus did a good job
of summarizing why we are recommending I
okay
repr thank you madam chair just a
technical question but I'm looking on
today's
calendar uh and it it it lists the bill
that we're going to be executing but
1070 is not on this list it's on the
amendment there was a calendar amendment
that came out ah okay thank you and also
it's on the back page if you didn't turn
it over if you have that
one ju just want to make sure we don't
step in something here I appreciate your
concern but the uh the motion the the
calendar Amendment went out we have a
few bills that were
duplicated but we we're only going to
vote on them once my my my point was not
to object just to make sure we don't
violate the rules thank you any other
discussion on
this yeah okay in that case the motion
is an expedient to legislate on House
Bill 1070 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative Lakers yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo nasso
yes representative Dolan yes
representative popovic Mueller yes clerk
vote Yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 19 y z
nay okay motion passes is there any
objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that on consent House Bill 1454
representative gr you have a motion yes
um I would like to move itl on how House
Bill
1454 is there a
second I'll I'll second
okay do you wish to speak to your
motion yes I do thank you madam chair um
you might recall that um House Bill
1454 um requested that daycare workers
licensed daycare workers be allowed to
um enter into the um retirement fund for
state
workers and that they would pay for
their um the fee for their for that U
benefit however the sponsor of the bill
brought us an amendment that who intent
was that the state would pay for that
benefit
and my concern with that bill was
that if license daycare workers were
allowed to enter the state employee
benefit program what would prevent
others from also doing that and they are
not state
employees so although I'm sympathetic to
the plight of daycare workers in New
Hampshire because I think that we read
about that quite a bit I don't feel that
this is an appropriate way of um
addressing that
representative lus do you wish to speak
that covered it okay anyone
else representative Brown uh thank you
Madame chair I'll repeat the comment I
made during the hearing uh state workers
now pay for a small portion of their
health insurance so if this passed the
childcare workers would be getting a
better health care benefit than your
state employees would yes and looking at
the numbers we were given it would be
about a third more people in in the plan
depending on how many took it up and I
can't imagine they wouldn't all take it
up if it's
free so I I don't think that's something
we want to sign up
for anyone
else okay the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1454 and the clerk and call the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative sanon naso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
popovic Mueller yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative man japy yes
and the chair yes 19 yay z n all right
any objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that on
consent and on House Bill
1112 I move in expedient to
legislate I'll second 11 12 second by
repr BR
no that thank
you
and
I don't think we got any convincing
testimony that this is
something Welcome
Back The Rance of My Demise ex I am so
glad to hear
that if you say so yeah
right so anyway there was no indication
that human trafficking was a subject
that we should should mandate every
healthc care worker takes a continuing
education class for on every license
renewal cycle we recommend that
everybody take one of the many available
courses on the
topic but more than once or maybe you
know every five or 10 years it it seemed
like it would be a redundant effort um
and we've heard
that mandating class cles that
aren't updated is a good way to get
people to not pay attention to what
their requirements are
so I recommend
itl sh I'll just State further that um
while the committee does not feel this
should be mandated uh it certainly would
be within the perview of the
professional boards to include some kind
of training on this if they choose to
yes the testimony was that there are
quite a number of such classes available
but uh and we would certainly want to
recommend people take one of them at
least representative Schmidt and then
sign I just want to clarify Madam chair
representative O'Brien was just walking
in the door as you were as you were
making your motion so is going to be
able to you restated your itl motion the
question has not yet been called he we
in the discussion section thank you
madam chair thank you representative
Simon thank you madam chair I will be
supporting the itl I just wanted to
comment I think I'd be more sympathetic
towards this bill um if it was just a
one-time training at the beginning of
service uh just to make sure that people
have exposure to the topic which I do
think is an important one um but as you
we did we never had an amendment to that
effect so as you've uh pointed out uh
having it done on a regular basis is um
cumbersome in isn't going to help them
in their actual studies okay anyone
else all right the motion is any spe to
legislate on House Bill 1112 and the
clerk can call the role represent Simon
yes represent lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo naso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
popovic meller yes clerk vote Yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 20 a z n any
objections to
consent seeing none we'll put that on
consent all right house bill 142 seven
Deputy Physicians does somebody have a
motion yes Madam chair I'll move itl on
House Bill
second by representative gold yes okay
thank
you all right do we speak to your motion
I do thank you um although I'm sympath
sympathetic with the um lack of um
healthc care availability healthare
providers in the North Country um this
um Bill establishes regulations and lure
for Deputy
Physicians and I have in with all the
work that we've done on oplc and all the
um attention that we've placed on
limiting
licensing and um remove I just don't
feel that this is an appropriate way of
of um of addressing this
need and with all the other um available
Health Care Providers such as nurses
lnas
aprns um physician
assistant assistance um I just feel that
this is not something that we need at
this time thank you representative gold
uh I think it's been stated well by
representative
groy thank you anyone
else I'd like to comment that
in addition to the question of whether
we need this level of lure the bill
essentially required our State Board of
Medicine to set up a an apprenticeship
program that's equivalent to a Residency
program and I wouldn't want to stick the
Board of Education with that the Board
of Medicine with that
task all right anyone
else all right the motion is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
1427 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
leakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative saso yes representative
Dolan yes representative popovic Mueller
yes clerk votes yes representative Boyd
yes representative Brown yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
O'Brien yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative manip py yes
and the chair yes 20 a0 name all right
any objections to
consent seeing none all right house bill
16001 representative s
Anastasia I move in expedient to
legislate for House Bill 1601 is there a
second I'll second all right do you wish
to speak to your
motion uh House Bill 1601 makes two
changes drug affordability board it
makes the uh executive director 10 year
four years and it removes the oversight
from the fiscal committee on the uh uh
bidding for contracts and because
there's no uh because it's uncommon to
do that I don't think that's necessary
to remove that
oversight represent
BR yes into testimony it was presented
if I'm not mistaken that um the drug
affordability board was in agreement
with this but it seems that there is a
conf there's a conflicting
um thought on this and until that gets
resolved I think we should take we
should address we should ital the bill
and also the department of
administrative Services is putting
together a report on the drug
affordability board and we should wait
until we get that report before we make
any changes thank you okay anyone
else just one second representative
Simon thank you madam chair the the only
thing that I remember from this bill
that I had concern with um was it seemed
to me that um by allowing one of our own
committees to oversee monies that had
already been
appropriated um we might be setting a
fairly dangerous precedent uh as far as
overseeing any funds that we've
appropriated to the executive um Branch
for for use it's just not something
that's typically done I do have um some
concerns about that um so I just wanted
to at least bring that to everybody's
attention again I actually think that
the um AG might be looking into that as
we
speak well then I would think we don't
want to step in front of Das and the
Attorney General would be that would be
a dangerous precedent for us to set when
we're not really sure we understand the
issues
involved represent
Schmid I just think that cutting the
fiscal committee out of oversight is not
a good idea okay anyone
else okay the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 16001 and the
clerk can call the role represent
Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo naso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
POA V meller yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
manuti yes and the chair yes 20 a z
name all
right motion passes 20 Z is there any
objection to
consent okay seeing
none think we will break for lunch
resuming at 100 p.m we have only five
bills
left good job every everybody and that
that will give time for all the people
making motions to write their committee
reports
wh
one
yeah
on
1689 St write minority
okay
okay welcome back
and representative Boyd has been pulled
into his other committee for which is
which which is also exing today he's
going to be there for one bill and then
he'll be he'll join us
um I'm going want to start with House
Bill 1410 representative
leus thank you I'd like to move to adopt
um Amendment uh
0534 to House Bill
1410 and seconded
by okay okay and you wish to speak to
your motion I believe I do um so this
bill did a wide range of uh of things um
one was to eliminate the uh licensing of
lnas now they already were required to
be registered under federal statute and
the idea was that U it would make the
process
easier um and cheaper for the lnas and
we certainly need more lnas and they
don't get paid a whole lot um however
and in the subcommittee we really worked
to see if we could do this and we got
through almost everything except there
was one hurdle which is um with just the
federal registration oplc could not
require a background check and if they
only worked at medical facilities they
could require but the problem is that
apparently there's a growing trend
for uh families to privately hire lnas
to assist their elderly relatives so
they can still be taken care of at home
and don't have to go to nursing homes
and all that and so the end we decided
um that we would we would leave the LNA
licensing and so this amendment removes
that from the bill this amendment
actually replaces the whole bill um the
the other thing almost in aside but uh
through the discussion uh director
Courtney thinks that um she may be able
to make things easier on the LNA as far
as the trouble and expense of Licensing
but through rulemaking without statute
so yeah and incidentally we have another
bill on the qualification for lnas that
we haven't yet heard that will also be
appropriate to consider the licensing
issues there okay now a lot of the rest
of the bill is just a statutory cleanup
uh there are a number of things that
where we gave the authority to um oplc
you know fee setting and various other
and actually issuing licenses and all of
that where um there are some cases where
the uh in statute the authority and
responsibility also remain with the
boards creating a conflict so like sort
of by volume the bulk of this actually
is uh cleaning that up another minor
clean up which is including aprns with
RNs um as possible uh you know on the
board of nursing the other um
non-trivial change was it removes the
registration of medical technicians so
medical technicians are as defined in
the bill are are people who work who do
Healthcare work they're not not
otherwise licensed so they're not nurses
doctors any of that um and they have
access to
Pharmaceuticals and they uh they have uh
the possibility of contact with patients
and the idea I guess was to register
them and you know that be some process
for maybe dealing with complaints um
problem is is and this is testimony we
heard from oplc was that people in in
those jobs don't generally tend to see
it as a profession they can't they only
found one person ever who is at all
interested in serving on the board um
the board has never been able to meet
with a quorum because there only been
one person therefore the board has been
unable to create rules on anything which
means oplc can't do anything with regard
to the medical
technicians um I mean if they get a
complaint she said on a clearly criminal
matter they can refer to law enforcement
but otherwise and but anybody could do
that um so this this well you know I'm
sure well-meaning attempt to provide
some protection is just completely
non-functional and we don't see any way
it could be you know maybe some future
legislature can come up with a better
way of of solving what is perceived as a
problem but this isn't it and I want to
get you know I think we want to get rid
of it because it provides a i u you know
the view or or sets the impression that
the state is providing some protection
when it is not and that we shouldn't be
doing that
and that's basically it okay
representative Brown do you wish to
speak to your second uh no I think Tony
is representative lcus has covered
it okay representative Schmid thank you
madam chair so I second representative
Le's remarks or
third uh with regard to the situation
with the medical technicians that the
bill was well intentioned it was was
generated for a very good cause but the
bottom line is is it does not work and
therefore there's no no sense
maintaining it um and with the LNA
situation uh you didn't reference it but
as you probably know uh there are a lot
of lnas that work for nursing homes
where the background checks are
absolutely crucial those people are
dealing with a lot of people who are
easy to take advantage of if you're of
that disposition we cannot let those
people lose loose on the Nur own
population so perhaps you'd speak to
that yeah okay um represent I I don't
disagree I was just uh the reason I
emphasized the ones where they're
actually in somebody's home the nursing
home at least there's some management
there but if they're in somebody's home
there's nobody else same difference and
that was kind of the even worse yeah
okay okay representative man py thank
you madam chair I agree with uh
everything that representative laa said
my still my concern I was on the
subcommittee the concern that's hanging
loose is the medical technician one
there's there's no anchoring of that
responsibility any place and there are
you know they're not licensed they're
registered but no oversight kind of
thing so I'm hoping that future
legislation can bring some kind of a
oversight into that and that will make
it thank you representative leus yeah I
I understand the only thing I could say
is that medical technicians don't have
their own practice all working for some
employer who is responsible like any
employer for the action of their
employees and if somebody feels they've
been harmed their their you know open
liability at least that's something but
I understand yeah I I'd like to mention
that when we created that
registration um it was because the
employers were not acting responsibly to
discipline their
employees and that was the root cause
was found to be the root cause of of
most of the issues so
um yes representative gold thank you
madam chair I also served on the
subcommittee and I just want I agree
with everything that's been said by
everybody I just wanted to add regarding
the the right now oplc gets complaints
about people who fit under this category
of medical technician but with no board
to adjudicate the complaint and verify
whether it's a valid complaint or not
oplc is is prevented from taking any
further action unless it rises to a
criminal offense and there's been
several of these calls that have come in
and so it's creating an even more
dangerous situation where people think
they can complain to the state and then
the complaint is just sitting there and
nobody has the ability to act on it and
that it's causing stress for the staff
and a danger to the
public thank you representative Gould
anyone
else all right seeing none the motion is
is to adopt Amendment
3548 to House Bill
1410 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative leakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative saso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Popovich Mueller yes clerk votes yes
representative Brown yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 19 y
Zer all right representative leus you
have a
motion the motion is um ought to pass
with Amendment on House Bill 1410 second
seconded by representative gold all
right any fur any comments
Representative blackis no I since the
amendment replaces the whole bill and I
think we've discussed that enough I'm
I'm also represent gold same I'm good
okay anyone else comments questions
concerns in that case the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 1410 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative leakas
yes
sorry representative Bailey yes
representative santon naso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
poic Mueller yes clerk votes yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
O'Brien yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative mipi yes and
the chair yes 19 y0 nay right motion
passes is there any objection to
consent okay thank you we put that on
consent all right since we are still
missing representative Boyd on House
Bill 1075 in
1679 representative G do you have a
motion you can make on either of them
yes Madam chair thank you on um House
Bill 1075 relative to abolishing
Daylight Savings
Time um I want I'm I'm wondering if we
can uh continue the hearing or the vote
on that um as I'm working on an
amendment which should be do you have a
motion you could make now on 1679 I do
on uh House Bill 16 we do that one first
then nine Madam chair I move that we
retain that bill interim study is the
way for second year okay interim study
interim study all right is there a
second okay by representative GS second
by representative leus do you wish to
speak to your motion sure Madam chair we
have uh several bills we're looking at
and uh we'd like this bill retained to
be able to possibly um put an amendment
in but it needs some study
okay represent blackis thank you I agree
um I looked at this carefully and
there's actually some real defects in it
in the scheme for um when it would
become act effective and there's a
section there section three never can I
had a discussion with the prime sponsor
uh he agreed there's some other
technical problems and other problems
with the bill so it's certainly not
ready and interim stud is fine okay does
anyone else have a comment there a
question all right then the motion is
interim study on House Bill
1679 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
leas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo naso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
poic Mueller yes clerk votes yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie
yes representative Shu yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
mapy yes and the chair yes 19 y0 me all
right motion passes 19 to zero is there
any objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that one on
consent and
on House Bill
1075 that is not an early bill so we can
defer it to a later date
is um that is your your request
representative gold yes Madam chair
thank you all right this is something
that
um next week on Thursday the 15th the
session won't start until
1:00 um we can have a morning executive
session for this one bill if we like
since we're all going to be coming in
for the session or we can push it
further out into
March um but with the other bills we
have any uh anybody have a strong
preference one way or the
other well there might be we're going to
have some hearings next week right so
there might be other bills that we could
accept at the same time correct uh no
because we don't have the amount of time
they have to be well no we they have to
be either the same day as the hearing or
announced on the floor and this would be
before the floor so no it would be and
you know what today is February 6th or
7th already right so I'm thinking we're
two weeks ahead but we're really not
it's next week so so sorry February is
flying by yes February is flying
by yeah
all
right Madam chair I have no preference
whatever works for the committee okay
anyone does have a preference I'm kind
of thinking that an exec for one bill is
probably uh not per not
efficient
so we don't we don't have any other
bills so let's see when's the deadline
for um
deadline for first committee bills is
March 21st which is a
Thursday it's a one committee bill so
its deadline is the is uh March
21st so
um how about the when Wednesday before
that which would be the fourth the 13th
Mark
13th okay so we'll defer that
to
um March
13th and plan to exact the bills that
we're
hearing next week and the week after and
any others then as well that's about as
far as I want to
go okay all right so we will continue
the exec there
and and I don't want to take up the next
two until uh representative Boyd gets
here so let's take a take a uh 10-minute
break Madam chair a quick
clarification yes so on the 15th we are
not meeting before the session we are
just coming to the session great thank
you there's probably a there's probably
a caucus too
but um but anyway no we I don't want to
schedule a meeting for one bill unless I
have
to all
right take a
break write your committee
reports yeah but but we're we're going
to need an executive session
anyway for the bills that we've heard
that we didn't exact the day of so
by the way
ear
okay all
right
back by popular demand as has been
stated
um House Bill 1394 representative Gould
you have a
motion I would like to present an
amendment which you have
distributed um this is amendment number
99h if anyone doesn't have one I've got
a few
spares this amendment
is for the um do someone second this
amendment I'll second the amendment
thank you all right
um 039 99 all right this amendment is
the oplc comments and it cleans up
statutory conflicts that were in the
bill it it's it is of course
housekeeping which I will not say but
um it is it just cleans up the the uh
conflicting statutes I do not support
the bill itself but if there's support
for it I would want it to be as good a
bill as possible so that's why I'm
bringing this amendment forward
represent groa I agree that when we
present a bill from our committee it
should be as um perfect as possible and
I think um the chair for issuing this
amendment okay anyone else have a
question or a comment about the
amendment I missed it if you explained
what you have done with this amendment
it um it cleans up the statutory
references the conflict Ed
between last year's oplc statute and
this year's oplc statute essentially do
you want a copy of it I no I have it
okay I might add that the sponsor of the
bill really does issue the exact same
amendment that they had provided last
year without regard to the changes that
we had made so it was important that we
don't put in
legislation that conflicts with
something that we've already already
done especially when we have an
amendment that cleans it up right okay
anyone else plan then I'll did you get a
second yes representative groa seconded
okay anyone anyone else questions
comments on the
amendment all right the motion is to
adopt Amendment
1394 excuse me amendment 0399 to House
Bill
1394 and the clerk can call the role
represent Simon yes representative lakas
yes representative Bailey yes
representative santon nasso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Popovich Mueller yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
man py yes and the chair yes 20 a0 n all
right the motion the amendment is
adopted and representative gold your
motion is uh to pass on House Bill
1394 as amended with amend with
Amendment with Amendment thank you
representative Schmidt representative
Schmidt is keeping us to the straight
and arrow today I second Madam okay so
that's moved by representative gold
second by representative Manti do you
wish to speak to your motion I do Madam
chair the this bill allows the licensing
of Music therapists we heard a lot of
testimony before our committee in the
hearing on the importance of music
therapy to many different populations in
our state and especially to our veterans
we Face a mental health crisis in New
Hampshire and we're seeing the effects
of it it affects so many facets of our
community not only our own safe
well-being and happiness but our police
departments that are handling so many of
the The Fallout from the mental illness
rampant situation we have in our state
that every form of therapy I think is
excruciatingly important and music
therapists cannot be covered by
insurance without a licensing process
which means veterans and other citizens
who need the service and who will
benefit from the service and help to at
least deal with the effects of the
mental illness crisis cannot use those
Services through their normal insurance
they have to pay for it out of their
pockets so it leaves our most vulnerable
citizens unable to use a therapeutic
service that will benefit them thank you
represent man thank you madam chair
being a farmer speech therapist who used
music internation therapy for
communication especially with the
population of aasia which is stroke and
uh loss of speech post stroke this is a
common
predominantly uh seen in veteran
population as well as in the nonverbal
DD population so this is a very critical
piece and this will add to the toolbox
of uh rehab and therapeutic intervention
for many different population and I
think this will be a huge asset in terms
of provid proving opportunities for our
citizens here in New Hampshire thank you
madam thank you represent leus thank you
and uh not to denigrate anybody offering
speech therapy but I don't you know as
I've said before I think the only
legitimate reason to support um
occupational licensing is a real and
significant threat to public health and
safety and I don't see that from music
therapist I mean if there were somebody
had an idea of uh whether it was called
to license or whatever that would um
permit them to get reimbursed I think
particular issues are are Medicare
Medicaid I might support that but to set
up a whole licensing scheme and board
and all or include them in another one I
think it does um I just don't think it's
Justified so I can't support
it all right
yes so um I will be supporting this bill
and I'm hoping that um we can have a
floor discussion about
it all right well I I'm strongly opposed
we do have music therapists working in
New
Hampshire whether
they're they don't need a license their
employers recognize their skills and
hire them um and I like repres leus I
don't think that it's Justified to set
up this procedure simply because some
insurance companies don't want to cover
what is medically necessary or
appropriate represent Papa Miller thank
you madam chair just a very quick note
that if there is an issue with the
services of these people not being
covered under health insurance I think
that's a problem that we should look at
solutions for but to create a licens in
scheme that creates barriers to entry
and makes it harder for music therapist
to enter this field I just don't feel
this is the right solution I would be
happy to look at other ways to solve
that issue without making it harder to
for people to come into the
field okay oh
okay anyone else have a comment question
concern
represent I'll take up a couple seconds
to uh just make a comment um in regards
to representative leakes's comment about
uh this particular profession perhaps
not being a matter of life and death I
think uh there is something to be said
about quality of life and I believe that
the work that these folks do does
enhance the quality of life and perhaps
in some cases May um turn someone's life
around who is contemplating suicide for
example so thank you
representative leus yeah I I I thought I
try to make clear that you know I do I
see the value in them um and so it's not
a matter of saying there's no value but
um I think the risk of them practicing
it inappropriately and therefore causing
a significant risk to public health and
safety isn't there and that's the
justification for in my view for doing
licensing it's not saying they're
they're without
value thank you Simon
I would agree with that sentiment I I
think that the Divide on this bill is
not um whether or not we think music
therapy is effective um in treating um
people with certain in certain
situations uh I think there's General
agreement that that's more than likely
the case and that people should have
access to music therapy and nobody's
trying to block that uh The Divide just
comes uh I think between the two sides
on whether or not licensing is the
appropriate mechanism to do that my
major concern with the
um is on line 10 of Page Three where it
says no person without a license as a
music therapist shall use the title of
Music therapist or similar title or
practice music therapy um if I would be
more sympathetic to the bill if a music
therapist could continue in practicing
unlicensed but also had the option of
getting a license if they wanted to be
able to take insurance um rather than uh
especially since we don't uh at least if
I remember testimony correctly um there
aren't a lot of complaints that music
therapists are causing a great deal of
harm um and so it doesn't seem like it's
a safety issue um as far as poor poor
treatment is concerned so where we're
not protecting people in that regard um
and as representative um papovich uh
sorry how do you say it's papovich
Miller okay yeah um uh stated um I just
don't want to create that extra
um burden that extra uh step now now
somebody's going to have to go to a
licensing board and um get other
people's permission to practice in the
state of New Hampshire we haven't needed
that barrier um uh so I don't want to
implement it so if we could if if there
is a way of creating um a
solution where somebody could continue
to practice
unlicensed and there was also an Avenue
to get a license um so that the people
who need to can can um get insurance
coverage um I'd be much more apt to vote
in favor of the
bill anyone else yes represent gold
thank you madam chair i' just like to
respond to some of the comments we did
hear testimony that that this is a
science in that there are methods and
procedures that are therapeutic and
there is use of Music in ways that are
not therapeutic and are harmful in fact
to people and for anyone that would
question that I watched last night as
they were using torture by bluring loud
music at patients so I'm not insinuating
that anybody claiming to be a music
therapist would be torturing people but
the testimony we heard from the
professionals who were asking for the
licensing was that it can be harmful and
it can be applied in harmful ways so I
do think that safety is important and
and I agree that there should be other
ways to get insurance companies to act
in ways that honor what's healthy for
people but in I don't think the state
legislature can enact that and but what
we can do and the way the system is set
up whether we like it or not and I do
not like it is we can provide licensing
categories for professionals who have a
therapeutic millu behind them that
improves people's lives and that when
used in appropriately could harm people
and that will allow insurance companies
to reimburse for their services
okay thank you anyone else repres Simon
thank you madam chair just to to respond
to that for clarification purposes um I
don't think that what we're saying is
that harm can't be done but rather
within the state of New Hampshire is
harm being done is there are we
responding to to real harm and it didn't
I I don't remember anyway you can
correct me if I'm wrong I don't remember
any testimony over the last few years
that has brought forward um the idea
that people who are um
giving these services in the state of
New Hampshire have done so in in an
appropriate manner so the question would
be whether Licensing in New Hampshire um
is necessary in order to to create that
protection if people are doing this
unlicensed and we have no real incidence
of malpractice I guess um if we don't if
we don't really have that then I don't
see then we'd be fixing a problem that
doesn't exist in the state of New
Hampshire okay anyone else represent man
py thank you Madam chair just to
clarify there is no harm done but the
access to a therapy like this which is
for communication behavior
modification and uh other stress relief
specific to post-traumatic stress
disorder those kind of things are very
specified music therapy and that access
is not available to people who need it
the most at the time they need it
because there is no licensed pack in
terms of you know we have seen other um
you know like the yoga or other modality
non uh pharmaceutical or
non-medical uh modalities to treat
certain conditions and music therapy is
a certified it in other states as well
as in um other uh parts of the world
where it is very specifically trained to
do certain things for certain group of
population and it's it is very effective
so in order to say it's only when there
is a harm done done negatively that we
have to identify I think that's one way
of looking at it there's another
beneficial one preventive and early
intervention part of it so from that
point of view I think the music therapy
would be a beneficial tool for our
citizens in New Hampshire okay
all right anyone else need to say
anything in that case the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 1394 and the clerk and call the
role representative Simon no
representative Lakers no representative
Bailey no Representative santonastaso no
representative
Dolan no representative Popovich Mueller
no clerk votes
no representative Boyd no representative
Brown
no representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair no ten 10 n all
right the motion fails for lack
of the ti vote
I'll move in expedient to legislate on
House Bill
1394 is there a
second okay second by represent
laus um I don't think we need to rehash
the discussion represent leus do you
wish to add anything uh no thank you
okay anyone
else all right the motion is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
1394 and the clerk can call the Ro
representa Simon yes represent Lakers
yes representative Bailey yes
representative saso yes representative
Dolan yes representative poic
mu s yes and the clerk vote Yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes Representative groa no
representative Schmidt no representative
goalie no representative Shu no
representative
O'Brien no representative Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick
no representative Gould no
representative Smith no Representative
maputi no and the chair yes 10 yes 10
nay all right the motion failed 1010
therefore this bill will as expected go
to the floor without
recommendation representative gold
you'll write the motion the report in
favor ought to pass and representative
leus and I will write the report on in
expedient to
legislate Madam chair yes just a
parliamentary question will the um
amendment that was adopted appear in the
calendar yes it's the committee
Amendment thank
you thank you madam chair I'll have that
ready okay you want me to write down
your attor what what's that do you want
me to write down your attorney yeah put
down me we'll take care of it and
recycle the one from last
year all right our final bill House Bill
1676 representative laus you have a
motion and an amendment I believe I do
um I'd like to move that we adopt
Amendment
0478 H to House Bill
1676 I'll second the motion
okay
just your motion right so the original
bill um was to create a a commission to
um to review each of the licensing
boards and issue reports and
recommendations um on any changes that
might you know the commission thinks are
appropriate
um and it also um to kind of move the
commission along and doing their work
had uh repeals scheduled over some
period of of years of the licensing
boards well I never expected uh any of
them to actually get repealed and either
the commission would do the work or
somebody would put in something to get
rid of the repeals it generated a lot of
concern and I understand that and so
among other things this amendment
removes all the repeals other than it
repeals this the sunset commission after
five years well it's not Sunset anymore
by the way the name and the title
nowhere in there is it sunset because
it's not sunsetting anymore but um
there is in statute a requirement that
commissions um end after five years but
to make it explicit we put it in here um
now the
subcommittee uh met on this but we had a
limited amount of time uh we did come to
agreement on changes to the statement of
purpose which are in the
amendment and I made some changes
elsewhere in that line there was
language from the statement of purpose
parts of it that were elsewhere in the
bill and I removed or made changes to go
along with uh changes a statement of
purpose the other big change was um to
change the membership and there were
serious problems with the membership in
the original Bill and this changes it to
uh more typical of these sort of
commissions um and it's now two members
of house cedna one being for the
minority uh party appointed by the
speaker one member of House Commerce
Consumer Affairs is appointed by the
speaker and similarly for the Senate two
from Edna one minority and one from
Commerce and then in
addition um one public member
representing interest of businesses in
New Hampshire appointed by the Bia and
the thought there is you know
organizations that employ a lot of
people who are licensed it might make
sense to have them in there um executive
director of oplc or design uh two public
members
and then one public member and that's
appointed by the governor with consent
of the council one public member
representing Healthcare employers again
they since a large portion of people who
are licensed work in the health care
industry figure that makes sense to have
somebody who's involved in employing
them uh there and then there's the usual
the public members can't be licensed or
have any direct um interest in it which
is the same thing for public members on
the actual licensing boards
um and then the section of uh what the
commission should look
at is basically the same as before
although some of the introductory
language which had some text similar to
what was in the original statement of
purpose had been
changed um I know there was some concern
about these but if you look
at uh page two of the amendment starting
you know line
26 so the the the types of
Regulation that they're to consider is
is a long list and um for those who are
concerns if you look at the at the end
of the list these are just things and by
the way it's things that they
um they may consider right um let's
see these are things that they can
consider but there's nothing in here
that says what they have to pick and one
of the options is occupational license
the same as it is to today and the
report shall include its findings
recommendations um to enact legisl
legislation that and then there's a
whole list and there's an or in there at
line 15 on page three and the last one
is make no changes to the law so this is
um you know things that they can that
they are to consider but options they to
consider but it doesn't specify what
they have to do and there's nothing in
here that would uh tell the commission
they have to make an any change at all
if they think things are just fine they
are
um and then it also directs the
commission to you know look at the scope
of practice and the qualifications
required to get a license that's that's
the main things that uh the boards do
and look at other potential concerns um
and there is I think there was some
comment I don't know if was the
committee or subcommittee that we have
um you know the performance audits like
we recently we had the Dental Board and
the Mental Health Board those are
looking at whether or not the um board
or is following the statute created by
the
legislature and uh and are they doing it
in an effective and efficient manner but
it's not their charge or their business
to actually look at whether the
statutory scheme is um is really the the
the best and the thing is is that the
you know industry changes uh professions
change the technology the expertise uh
the techniques all of that and the needs
of the consumer change over the years
and some of these boards were put in
place many years ago and I think it's
good to uh you know step back and take a
look at each one and say you know to the
you know we need to protect public
health and safety but we want to put as
few barriers imp Poss as possible into
people like you know working are we
striking the right balance between those
two and if not what changes should be
made and maybe the answer is on you know
some boards it's it's just fine and
maybe most of them that would be up to
the
commission
um and that's uh that's basically it the
commission is required to put out a
report per board um there is no
scheduled dates when they have to put
out um a report because they can take
the boards in any order they want and I
can't predict that and so I can't say
there has to be um you know they just
have to do it before they're done um
other concerns I've heard are there's
already an oversight oplc oversight
committee but which I and others on this
you know on the committee here on but
that has the way it's working is it's
looking at current ongoing stuff so you
know how well is the rul making process
going to respond to statutory changes
and hearing about concerns from people
generally either either from the
licensed Comm people community people
who are licensed or from you know
potentially from uh customers of theirs
concerns about what's going on now and
from the those who are licensed you know
is oplc functioning well have they may
have complaints about delays or whatever
else and so that committee is looking at
current ongoing issues but it's not you
know doesn't have a charge of of looking
at restructuring the whole thing um the
other thing is that that's a committee
which means it can't have have anybody
on it by but legislators whereas a
commission can and I think it's
important to have um you know some
public members and members like
representing um you know major consumer
groups in other words a certain
business
um and uh that's that's basically I
think it's good periodically to step
back and take a look and see is is it
the right way I mean we've done a lot of
work we've done
restructuring of the bureaucracy to help
with the function but except where
there's been particular bills for
particular boards we haven't looked at
um you know the details of what's going
on with a particular board is the
statute right um are the rules right and
is it functioning the way it should and
I think it's a value to do that thank
you
br representative luus is a tough act to
follow first of all I want to commend
the committee and I want to commend
representative leus because this was a
lot of work and it represents a lot of
work we although I agree and I support
the amendment I don't support the
premise of the Bill of forming another
commission so but this this amendment in
my mind makes the bill significantly
better and I don't want the work and the
efforts and the passion that was put to
forth for this amendment to go
unrecognized so yes I will support the
amendment right thank you representative
goalie thank you madam chair um
I have trouble supporting this amendment
um another commission that gives a
report five years from now um made of of
legislators and Senators who may start
from when this is passed in an election
year to form members and those members
may not be here in two years to start
over and continue moving on
um I I just can't support but another
reason why I can't support this
is this commission is made up of
business folks and people have interest
in it doesn't have a single lensey on
the
commission not one license e to
represent their position as to why they
should be
there and I think that's important if
we're going to have a commission all the
stakeholders should be part of that
commission so with that being out I mean
I don't see I can't I can't support it
and then another
reason being once again those have been
around long enough see we have
commissions here that do work spend
three four years putting something
together that gets put into a binder
says we should do this and we should do
that and we should do this for
legislation and it gets filed and put
away because the legislature five years
from now is totally
different it's a lot of work done by
these members and this is what happens
and it's reality
folks those that have been here long
enough know it's
reality so when we had the committee on
committees and Commissioners to get rid
of a lot of these this is one of the
reasons why because of what
happens
and I'll just leave on one last note
that we already have
the oversight committee on oplc and we
have
Audits and then anybody else has the
right to look at any of the boards like
we see legislation coming in year after
year after year to try and
change a certain board to advisory not
to advis
should we license this individual what
should we do to not license it's being
done we don't need a commission to tell
us which boards need oversight which
boards need what's going on it's being
done now so I can't support this thank
you
okay repres represent man py and then
leus and then she thank you madam chair
I did serve on the subcommittee it was a
lot of work and I commend uh
representative L for putting ours in
painstakingly working diligently on
getting the amendment again many of the
reasons um stated by representative
goalie my concern is also creating
another commission and holding the
future legislator responsible and future
members who are not even we don't even
know who's going to be on it hold them
hold their feet to the fire to get
things done I don't think we can do it
as a current sitting legislation
legislators so from that point of view I
have a huge concern and again another
commission to oversee the
committee's
commissions doesn't make any double
negative doesn't make it positive in
this case thank you much representative
leus um thank you just uh to deal with
uh some concerns about uh the board um
if you look in the bill it's not the
idea that that at the end of five years
they're going to put out a report
they're directed to do a report per
board and they would you know presumably
come out when they were done with it so
I would expect a series of results I
mean coming out and um maybe in five
years they don't get through all the
boards I hope they would but you never
know I you can't and we have plenty of
commissions that exist that aren't being
gotten rid of that seem to be doing
doing good work
that have been and continue on for a
period of years and people are working
on them and they are producing uh
results and so I don't think that well
you know certainly I I recognize the
risk that the commission might not do
anything effective and we can't make
them do that we certainly have plenty of
examples of commissions that are meeting
and doing ongoing good work um and
that's uh anyway that's that's uh
hopefully to deal a little bit with that
concern repres
sh thank you madam chair um I will be
supporting the amendment uh primarily
because a lot of language in the
original bill that talked about
repealing specific boards um and
rightfully or not uh we heard from a lot
of the board members that that uh
intimidated them so I think the
amendment uh is an improvement to the
bill but I also feel um that we probably
don't need another commission so I'm not
sure that I'll be supporting the final
Bill thank you
okay representative Brown uh thank you
madam chair um being being a an
first session person I I'm not sure that
I would agree because you have a lot of
commissions you can't have another one
I'm not sure that I agree with that
philosophy if you have a
a reason to have a commission that makes
sense I don't necessarily agree that you
just don't have one because you don't
want another
one um and then I guess I would if I may
follow up on
that
um the nature of the Beast of this
legislature is people change every two
years and and with respect to
representative goalie's comment that is
the nature of how it works so you got if
you have a commission that goes on for
five years it very likely is going to
have new people people on it and that's
kind of how it's supposed to work I
would guess thank
you all right I'd like to mention one
piece of testimony we got from the
pharmacy
board they were updating their rules as
is necessary once in a while and they
found their statutes were so convoluted
that they were having trouble with it
this has happened before um I completely
recodified the statute on licensing
of uh
investigators and and security agents
because that happened we make changes
every year as several people have
mentioned and some of these statutes
have been around for a long time and
they need to be cleaned up so that it's
not entirely clear that the original
concern has been met and it's not clear
that it's being implemented efficiently
I there are so many things things that
we do that get amended and tweaked and
revised and updated and amended again
that we do need to go back every once in
a while and say hey let's take a a CLE
look at this as a clean slate and figure
out are we doing the right thing if we
are doing the right thing are we doing
it in the best way and I hope that this
that's what this commission would
do
yes representative goalie thank you
madam chair and I just you know I don't
want to let the work that representative
leus did go on noticed and I appreciate
what he's trying to do but like I said
my one of my big concerns is there's no
licenses on this commission and we have
businesses we have the medical field
represented but no license e thank you
okay
represent thank you madam chair so I I
also salute the tremendous amount of
work that uh representative leus has
done to defang the original uh possible
uh negative
ramifications of what I now recognize is
likely to be either called the tedium
commission or the air guitar commission
uh because uh this is largely what it's
going to be it's not that it couldn't
have some beneficial effect but this is
going to be a lot of cardboard chewing
uh for the for the commission but the
real negative effect of the commission
is it's going to require every
profession that the commission takes up
to mount a defense of of every aspect
it's going to waste a tremendous amount
of time of the practitioners who are
going to have to come in and defend
their
profession um so does
this
amendment make an momentous Improvement
in the orig original Bill yes so I
salute my colleague uh whom I respect uh
but I I predict that uh this is not
going to be a commission that any
legislator is going to want to serve
on there are some of the
definitely all right representative
leus first of all thank everyone thanks
to everyone for their kind words um any
commission that's created and there are
plenty of them there is the risk that
the people on the commission don't do
anything um we can't do anything about
that but there is evidence there's
plenty of commissions that are actually
doing good work um the other thing
is um because the commission is is
directed to to look at each board
you know the the people who are licensed
from the professions they're not all
going to have to be there for their
meetings when the board's taking up um
when the commission is looking at
particular boards then you know they
would have an interest in coming
in um but they don't all have to be
there all the time so um the other thing
is that you know as I've stated
before the purpose of Occupational
licensing is to protect public health
and safety it is not for the benefit of
those licensed now the commission is
certainly going to need the input from
people who are licensed you know for
their subject area of knowledge and
they're going to be presumably showing
up as was mentioned um before the board
but having them actually on the uh
commission I don't think is appropriate
that's that's the reason why it's not
disrespecting them or accusing them of
anything or whatever it's just the
nature of the purpose of Licensing that
I don't think that that's appropriate
um and because the board's supposed to
put as I said put out a report on
different Commission on different boards
then everybody doesn't have to be here
and they don't have to do one giant
report at the end and there could be an
opportunity then as in reports come out
on boards that legislation could be
introduced if that's what the commission
recommends thank
you
okay representative goalie you can get
through last last El just briefly mam
chair I I disagree with because you're
looking at licensing that a license
shouldn't be part of the commission um
there are plenty of commissions out
there where all stakeholders are
participating on the commission um it's
important that you get views from all
sides when you're making those votes um
as a commission or a committee um so me
and my colleague disagree on that thank
you
okay all right in that case the motion
is to adopt Amendment
0478 H to house Bill
1676 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes represent Bailey yes
representive santon oaso yes represent
Dolan yes represent poic Mueller yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
gr gr Excuse me yes represent Schmidt
no represent goalie
no representative Shu yes representative
O'Brien no representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick
yes representative gold yes
representative
Smith yes repres
Manti
no and the chair
yes 16 yay4 nay okay the motion
has passes 16 to4 the amendment is
adopted representative leus you have a
motion I do I'd like to pass uh move
ought to pass with amendment to for uh
House Bill
1676 is there a second second second by
representative Brown okay uh any further
discussion I think I mean from my
standpoint I think I've covered it okay
representative Brown no representative
Schmid
and then represent thank you madam chair
so I voted against it just kind of
protest uh because again I think the
ultimate effect of the commission is
going to be a largely a waste of time um
uh and um but at the same time I'm not
hostile to the idea that the awful
original
Bill uh in terms of its effect um has
been neutralized by the fact that we've
amended it it with something that is
clearly much much better even if
essentially um kind of an air guitar
situation uh so I will be voting no on
the overall Bill thank you represent
gold thank you madam chair it was my
great pleasure to work with
representative leus and the rest of the
committee subcommittee on this amendment
and um and thank you everybody for that
voted to support it and understand those
who didn't I wanted to point out two
things I did advocate for um two of the
board members the one appointed by The
Business Association and the medical
person be removed from the precluded
licensing people so we'd have two public
members who were not licensed and then
two professional the other two could be
um lenses from the professions but um
you know so we had a difference of
opinion on that
um and then the when we had the hearing
on the way out after the hearing some of
the professional people who took time
out of their day to come in and talk to
us and to hear the work we were doing on
this were very very clear that if we got
rid of the repeals and that language
that was in the original bill that 98%
of them would support it so again I just
really want to commend representative
leus that he heard that and he heard
what the people were asking for and he
was able to make the amendment at the
end of the day I really do um I listen
very carefully to the work that se that
representative Dolan's doing on his
committee I understand um that for those
working committees and commissions it's
so hard to get appointments made when
they have a stack of appointments
they're trying to make because we just
keep growing these committees and
commissions and I've expressed some
concern over that so um I I I probably
will be voting no on this bill and
hoping another solution can be brought
up repr man and thank you madam chair um
thank you representative leakas for all
the hard work no disregard to all the
hard work having served on several of
these Commissions in my 12 years as a
legislator um I know what it takes the
amount of time commitment and um stuff
so having done that I still cannot
support the amount of time and effort is
needed to lift this whole commission up
in terms of what the duties are going to
be so from that point of view I will not
be able to support this bill and um I
did thoroughly enjoy working and
debating thank you represent Dolan Madam
chair um while I I voted in favor of the
amendment as I think it made it
significantly better I don't think it
made it good enough to to support the uh
uh the base bill so I'll be voting no on
the
otpa okay thank you representative
Simon thank you madam chair I just I
felt like the committee was having a
moment uh during this conversation and I
didn't want to be the only one not
thanking representative lakas for all
the hard work that he put into this bill
so I just wanted to take a moment and do
that uh before it was too late thank
you all
right anyone
else okay not seeing any more comments
the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 1676 and the
cler can call the RO representative
Simon yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Sasso yes representative Dolan no
representative poic Mueller yes clerk
votes yes representative voy yes
representative Brown yes Representative
groa no representative Schmidt no
representative goalie no representative
Shu no representative O'Brien no
representative Davis
no representative Fitzpatrick no
representative Gould no representative
Smith no
represent man jaui no and the chair
yes n9a 11 n okay the motion fails 9 to1
is does someone have an alternate motion
well I'd like to um ask for a
parliamentary if I could ask for a
parliamentary question if this is not an
early bill is it is an early bill it is
I believe so
yes
okay because my thought is I do think
that having a proactive look at the work
that oplc does including the lenses is
important I just don't like this vehicle
as the means of doing that so if the
committee will entertain this idea I'd
like
to offer a non-gain Amendment
to add the responsibility of this to the
oplc oversight committee so that the
work is done and I'll work with
representative Maguire representative
luus and representative goalie who are
all on the oversight committee other
than me so I'll be glad to address that
if the committee and likes that
idea for parliamentary question this is
in fact an early Bill Brad yes I thought
so uh and in that case representative uh
groa the appropriate motion would be
interim
study okay I'll move interim study on
House Bill 1676 second repres BR a
second by representative
Schmidt
okay and you have spoken to your motion
you want to add to it I don't want to
add anymore I just would like everybody
to go home by
2:30 you are such an optimist represent
GR representative
Schmidt uh I think that it's a step in
the right direction toward what we all
recognize is uh the Paramount importance
of having the oplc oversight committee
be extremely diligent and effective in
improving the oplc which still needs a
lot of
work just thank you anyone else wish to
speak represent LE right just sort of a
clarification for some people um by
doing this rather than itl it means that
we can consider the amendment uh that
representative groa graciously uh
suggested on another bill whereas I
think if we itail it we couldn't and
that's that's the big difference
yes or we we could consider making that
Amendment we could do other things to
review the the structure of
regulations but it doesn't man it
doesn't permit it forbid us from doing
anything represent Brown thank you madam
chair so for my clarification there's an
oversight committee that is watching
over
oplc
functions and if this gets into that
oversight
committee you you would be watching oplc
to make sure that they're watching over
the boards is that what I'm hearing I no
uh depending on what the amendment
finally gets worked out it would
it could add an extra duty to it to say
pick a profession examine the regulatory
structure and say do we need to make
changes thank
you okay anyone else and if I might add
it would allow the oplc oversight
committee to use existing data that's
been generated by audits or other types
of information that's been gathered so
they become re iCal for all of the
information that's been collected so far
including performance audits which are a
vital tool which we are not using enough
in this
committee thank you representative uh
Dolan thank you madam chair having uh
voted no on the otpa motion I will be
supporting interim study uh that's just
been proposed I believe that it this
gives us an opportunity to uh
incorporate some of the good work that's
been done and at least uh consider it uh
going forward okay thank you anyone
else okay in that case the motion is
interim study by representative groa and
the clerk can call the role
representative
Simon yes represent Lakers
yeses keeps cutting out representative
Bailey yes representative santon oaso
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Popovich Mueller yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
fit Patrick yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 20a is your
name all right does anyone object to
consent the motion
passes okay seeing none we will put that
one on
consent thank you all for your your work
those of you who have not made motions
and do not owe committee reports or have
already turned turn them in thank you
representative Davis thank you
representative
uh goalie no you didn't make any motion
sorry de representative Shu and and
others and representative Schmidt yes
you too yes
we thank you for coming in and we will
see you on see you tomorrow in session
if you still owe a committee report
please turn it in this immediately Madam
chair yes if I may uh
everyone before you leave I would just
like to congratulate our chair uh we
have completed the work on our early
bills and we had a slew of them and uh
it took an effort on everyone's part but
it was mainly her organization that made
it happen so thank
you